hi leute ich habe heute ein kleines
experiment mit euch vor und zwar weil
ich letztens in einem spielwarengeschäft
und habe obwohl es eigentlich schon nach
silvester ist diese ganzen knallerbsen
gekauft und heute habe ich vorher stimmt
schon titels zu sehen aus diesem 500
knallerbsen eine einzige zu machen
vielleicht gehen ein paar kaputt oder
sowas oder ein paar cent nicht aber ich
bin aber mal extrem gespannt ob das
überhaupt funktioniert also wir kriegen
als auf jeden fall hinter aus irgend
eine fette knallerbsen zu machen ist
würde ich sagen
am anfang das ja so ein bisschen
sägemehl drin müssen wir das erstmal ab
7 damit wie die knallerbsen einzeln
haben und dann wickeln wir in ein
taschentuch und lassen das explodieren
also es ist wahrscheinlich ziemlich
aufwändig für so ein kleines video aber
ich habe zumindest darauf und belegen
einfach mal los da anwender zeigen was
nur die allernötigsten sicht fahren sie
fahren nämlich übrigens leute wenn wir
das jetzt aufgenommen haben
nach paris und ich schneide das video in
zug nach paris also muss das jetzt
funktionieren das heißt egal ob das
extrem eine positiv oder negativ
verläuft werde ich das video hochladen
so sieht das übrigens aus leute überall
knallerbsen verpackung hier drin sind
die verbliebenen ich würde das jetzt mal
was jetzt das spannungsfeld müssen wir
jetzt ganz eng für die uns löschen
[Musik]
den rest machen wir daraus aber leute so
sehen schon 1 510 knall ersten gar nicht
so viel wie man dachte eigentlich finde
ich ok da wir nehmen jetzt die einzelnen
knappen ich würde sagen wir nehmen uns
mal einen raus und dann vergleichen wir
die jäger sind ja in so einem weißem
papier eingewickelt und dass er selbst
einmal durch dieses taschentuch
ich weiß echt nicht wie stark die
erosion wird dann war es enthält 500 mal
eine kneipe könnte schon ganz stark sein
zwerge auch schon interessant genug
diese ganzen 500 apps auf einmal
explodieren zu lassen aber zu langweilig
[Musik]
leute und dann ist etwas passiert womit
wir echt nicht gerechnet haben wir
gerade so diese diese kügelchen dieses
granulat was in der knall erste drin ist
aufeinander gestapelt und das war die
100 oder so was wie wir aufgemacht haben
er ist einfach ohne weiteres das
passiert was jetzt gerade nicht gesehen
bzw gehört habt war wie stark diese
explosion war also ist jetzt nur ein
zeitraffer es gibt insgesamt vier frames
und man sieht halt einfach nichts das
ding ist aber den dieses granulat wasser
auf den tisch das ist einfach so laut
und stark explodiert dass unsere ohren
geputzt haben und das war einfach
richtig richtig ekelhaft
also ihr habt das recht nicht gesehen
gerade aber das war so eine heftige
explosion kritisches ganz vorn gar nicht
damit gerechnet unsere das waren jetzt
vielleicht 100 apps also wirklich macht
das nicht frau sei nach wie vor
gefährlich und vor allem einfach so
angefangen zu tiefsten und also das war
echt nicht gut
hätten wir es mit 500 so gemacht dann
wäre wahrscheinlich der tisch hier in
die luft geflogen früher oder später
deshalb wie gesagt ich dir jetzt einzeln
paktieren ein taschentuch und ich habe
meine mal gehört zu haben dass sie da
nicht alle explodieren sondern nur
einzeln halte aber die tasten haut so
also wir machen das jetzt alles zusammen
hoffen dass es wieder funktioniert aber
das kann eben war viel zu passiv 500
viel zu gefährlich
wir haben das jetzt vorbereitet
nähmaschine einfach wie man probleme
ich wünschte ich hätte keinen zeitraffer
aufnahmen gemacht weil dann sieht man
halt immer nur so ein paar bilder pro
sekunde nicht 30 pro sekunde - fände ich
was sich bewegt deshalb habt ihr leider
nicht direkt gesehen aber es war viel so
wir testen das ganze jetzt aus das sind
das mich leben wahrscheinlich noch 400
knallerbsen die übrig sind meine ohren
liebsten immer noch von der explosion
gegeben
also wirklich leid gesehen
also das war die explosion ziemlich gut
abgegangen
die scheint auch wirklich alle geplatzt
zu sein aber ich glaube das wäre kein
vergleich zu dem wenn man durch nur die
steine genommen hätte was auch immer das
sein mag alles drin ist geplatzt
vielleicht gibt es ein paar einzelne
ganzen aber also ihr seht schon wir sind
alle einzeln platz wobei so ein paar mal
schütteln im close-up schaut sind schon
einige noch gar nichts aber die mehrheit
ich weiß nicht wie der unterschied war
von der explosion her und das pc kann
etwas viel zu treffers von der kameras
die letzten paar werden wir mit den
füßen platzen lassen dann brechen wir
das ganze ab übrigens verschieden 2017
sind prox vielleicht auch noch mal wobei
ich mache mich lieber nicht noch mal
falls ja muss ich mir jetzt ein bisschen
sicherer gestalten also ich war paris
last gern ein leichter fahrzeugklasse
verein hat obwohl zu schief gelaufen ist
es nervt mich wirklich zu tode dass man
nicht gesehen hat wie das alles
explodiert ich meine wenn es schiefgeht
unsere ohren dabei draufgehen man sollte
man es wenigstens 10
aber schreibt mal knallerbsen die
kommentare wenn ihr noch dran seid und
nach dem jetzt beim nächsten mal wieder
bis dahin und füße